is there anything else that like haven't
met your expectations or haven't met
your preconceptions yeah I want to know
is like a non right oh like you know one
job this is gonna sound dumb as [ __ ]
right and I know it's gonna sound dumb
but I like I knew things were going to
be difficult that I couldn't speak
Japanese or read Japanese
I'm also read than anything I feel like
you can for some reason you can be fine
not speaking Japanese here though if you
can't read like you're in for like a
storm of troubles
because there are so many things and I
think you all can agree honest if Amazon
didn't exist here and have oh my god if
Amazon didn't have English settings here
I genuinely don't know what I would do
because the websites here in Japanese
just like I don't know if they've done
this on purpose Porsche do you have the
old interface they do not work well with
Google Translate or going back to that
like 90s web they don't know how to
design their websites it's not user
friendly so if you can't speak Japanese
or read Japanese you're kind of [ __ ]
yeah yeah and the track the Google
Translate does not hell no it doesn't
help you can help you like feel like you
kind of feel your way through but you
cannot tell what the [ __ ] you're doing
the only reason we've been able to get
through it is because we've had [ __ ]
friends your company helping us makes it
so much easier for all oh yeah Joey yeah
Joey Joey helped me a lot when I only
moved here like help me out doing all
the thing right so you'd think like in
the big population areas they'd have
like a lot of English support but I
think they said like if you come on
these certain days like sending up
internet remember how much of a hassle
that was good like I remember that a you
right they say they have an English
location juku oh that's a [ __ ] lie no
no location is that they have a tablet
which can call a call center that can
translate the person for you kind of but
not really but that's the close in did
you again that box I don't even get to
the guy on the tablet I just turned up
saying on the website this says this is
the honest location and they were like
no and I'm like what what do i do how
the [ __ ] do I get Internet yeah help me
like ie luckily I had a cousin who
worked in Japan so she could speak
Japanese she helped me through so much
and
I don't know what I would do without her
yeah and you know same with you yeah she
did like you a lot like a baby
quite i I genuinely don't know like how
there are some foreigners here who can't
even speak English yeah um yeah lady but
yeah on their own I'm like how the [ __ ]
did you do that because at least they
have a lot of English words right and oh
yeah a lot of English options yeah yeah
yeah you speak it can't speak English
[ __ ] I don't know what I don't know how
they like English is hard enough as it
is
if you can't speak Japanese then I think
you're pretty much [ __ ] if you can't
positive message coming out of this
episode because that's the thing a lot
of people don't talk about which is how
hard it is to live here actually live
here without speaking Japanese because
go coming in like we said it's so
different living here as you know
working here and just live visiting here
as a tourist yeah yeah yes there's a
world of difference and there's so many
little things like for example
registering with the Town Hall yeah how
the [ __ ] am I supposed to do that if I
don't speak Japanese because they don't
they don't speak English and all the
forms were in Japanese yeah the form
Sates how you do that you need to do
that within two weeks of moving here
yeah or also in in Japanese the people
just learn Japanese who eats the ghee
the only reason we knew is cuz the
lawyers told us hey you've got to do
this but like if we didn't know that I
don't know what I was gonna just carried
on less you need a dedicated agency just
to help you with all the admin stuff
because I mean I can understand the
language and I still have to like learn
from like my cousins who live here that
like yeah [ __ ] and register like my
address and like my health certificate
and all of that [ __ ] like yeah I never
had to experience that being Australian
yeah a bad experience that while
visiting here right so it's just it's
it's overwhelming and like I
it's like massive kudos to people who
don't know Japanese or even don't know
English yeah again I don't know how the
[ __ ] they do it without the help of an
agency light six to clarify you you
can't live here if you don't speak any
Japanese or feel learning but I think if
you're somehow coming here alone without
anyone helping you it's gonna be hell